[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what kind of mission is this everyone
here is the best there is who's going to
teach us
they will start with what you only think
you know nice
what the hell easy maverick let's try
not to get fired on the first day we're
going into combat on a level never seen
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you i'm not going to
make the same mistake
oh my god here we go
top gun maverick pg-13
we are cleared into the area verified
cameras are on all right here we go
three two one
here comes
[Music]
all right
that was awesome
i wasn't ready to make a sequel until we
had a special story worthy of a sequel
and until technology evolved so we could
delve deeper into the experience of a
fighter pilot
the first movie became something that
changed a generation
so this is exciting to come back and get
those jets again
we worked with the navy and the top gun
school to formulate how to shoot it
practically because if we're going to do
it we're going to fly in the f-18s
the aviation sequences had to be real
so our actors went through three months
of ruling training
the navy says if you eject you have to
be able to survive in the water so we
had to go through that challenging
underwater program
it's intense you're flipped inverted and
you're having to try and get out
from there tom designed this
all-encompassing aviation training for
all the actors
i started them out in a single-engine
airplane
to build up their spatial awareness
inside the aircraft
next we took them to the l-39 and they
went and flew aerobatics to feel what
it's like in a jet
speed
from there they'd graduate to the f-18
super hornet and actually launching off
an aircraft carrier
the actors also had to learn how to run
the cameras because when they're up in
the jet they have to direct themselves
essentially okay
i had to really teach them
cinematography and the lighting so that
they understood what's going to look
good on camera
is great
everybody thought it would be impossible
for actors to really be in the jets
but that's the gift that tom gave us
that by the time we got up there
we could handle it
definitely the most amazing thing i've
ever done all the training 100 prepared
i'm very proud of what we all accomplish
each one of them are extraordinary
it still blows my mind that we've done
this
there's nothing like it
you